[Musique]
l'auditoire que nous serions toujours
meilleurs amis dit ici les garçons n'aiment pas
les filles qui sont trop sérieuses mais avez-
vous été ravi d'être libre les
missiles soviétiques pourraient effacer de la surface
de la terre les États-Unis et l'
Europe I  pense que nous devrions faire quelque chose
tu sais protester que le monde entier soit
mis en pièces à tout moment elle a raison
ça devient sérieux la seule vie
est celle que nous avons
maintenant c'est pourquoi nous devons la saisir Je pense que des
roses dans la fournaise qu'est-ce que
tu  ne peux pas dire gingembre que ne peux-tu pas dire
je t'aimais Rosa mais nous sommes différents
tu rêves d'amour éternel
pas moi
j'aime notre monde
je veux que nous vivions tous
[Musique]